[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
peux pas y tomber un mort de maman et
maman est tombée amoureuse
du fric
de papa et anna et vous ayez un ces
écoutes elle me fait deux enfants bout
de temps à mon ami mais trésor d'amour
tel point que maintenant et ses fils ait
rien me tiens par les
fumées des soldats soit de voir j'aime
avec les saints se situe qu'à soigne
voilà les moins chers
pour faire elle va moins vite en tout à
l'heure ça marchera pas
et prend ce quad et marc pâtes à l'eau
tu as soif bah ouais je prends pourquoi
j'arrive
j'espère vous avez soif
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
je vais sauter sur mon ami elle n'est
pas au courant j'espère qu'elle va crier
à la même pas vu elle est passée à côté
de moi elle est toujours dans ses
pensées notre isabelle morini bosc
on va voir ce que ça va donner j'essaie
de lui faire peur
de moi ton corps baby
[Rires]